[Music]
in [ __ ] that [ __ ] news [ __ ] that [ __ ]
budget by Hannah Messina I think I
pronounced that it's a real name first
and last call hi hi hey woman's eye
infection turned out to be something far
more disgusting what is it oh no is it a
cockroach it isn't a bug is it a spider
is a eggs Oh No is it a oh it's a bee
it's bees and then we're feeding off her
tears isn't it yeah it was
I remember her tears hmm I read about
this too inside why are they stuck in
there they feed off of her tears yeah
yeah
are they there are they making her cry a
lot ah inner tear-duct this chicks like
I watched so many wrong coms and these
bees are like oh yeah
she must have sweet tears this is a
Taiwanese woman and she had this like
eye infection day like she just had
severe pain in her eye and she [ __ ] does
she not know she had bees in there
they're pretty big she's allowed air
conditioners [ __ ] there's a kind of
thing that makes me not want to be a
person anymore
yeah correct yeah so crazy so she's 29
she went to the hospital and they found
these bees feeding on her tear ducts
under her swollen eyelids they got stuck
in there so what happened is she was
tidying a relative's grave with her
family so she was squatting down pulling
out weeds and so these types of bees
they nest near graves and fallen trees
[ __ ] my eyes itchy dude I know and
then what happened uh so that's how they
got in so she assumed that it was sand
or some kind of dirt that had cotton it
was larvae all right
they didn't say that but they were just
saying that it was their small you have
to be small because a big [ __ ] if a
bunch of them went in not once you would
know there was a bunch of them okay just
tweezer dit out she the doctor said I he
looked under microscope and saw insect
legs lowly one at a time without
damaging the bodies pulled them out
without damaging us your eyes they're
called sweat bees oh those they like
buzz around your arms and [ __ ] trying to
suck up your sweat mmm so they wanted to
pull them out in taxa didn't want to be
they look like ants I oh yeah they look
like an ant yeah cuz that's a you gotta
zoom in like a [ __ ] my eyes oh
that's nasty you know what I saw this
morning it was so gross you know that
[ __ ] worm that something worm that
looks like a lotus seed whew thank you
what is a lotus seed look like it looks
disgusting if you have that phobia of
like old looking thing which I prefer
beer Trappe oh [ __ ] yeah you don't want
to see this [ __ ] but it's that there's a
worm that grows on a doggies and animals
and then they they in live they
literally look like that you got to push
them out like oh you big white heads or
black hair it's even on your dog's no
he'll not a lot of ladies have those
when there's bowels watch I was
scrolling through the instagrams and
then someone had it and I was like I'm
follow you do like why the [ __ ] would
you do such a thing dude on insta story
sometimes I'm like okay this is not a
[ __ ] blog dude or vlog like what the
[ __ ] is with people doing 50 Instagram
stories I'm like bro and they're just
like talking the whole time no I just
was inspired by what Joe just said and
I'm just trying to get pissed off very
since the Instagram stories lets you
continue recording
how come mine doesn't do that it should
update you did you update that sometimes
I get stuck on somebody's thing so I
have to push it on everyone and then
they do so you could just swipe yeah
okay so this one person does it like I'm
not inkay like 75 you just go you swipe
it yeah you swipe and it goes to the
next person turn my phone off more if
you swipe off the whole thing like oh no
cuz no cuz I will usually watch like a
friends and then you're usually it's
like very quick and then it goes to the
next person and I'm like oh no it's just
first began [ __ ] I usually I usually
double tap the thing and I swipe up
Instagram shut Instagram down but then
when I reopen it opens the same [ __ ]
thing up and I'm like I know you're
doing it all wrong I didn't know thank
you guys I didn't know the [ __ ] that's
fine I don't usually watch stories but
the two people that I make it a point to
go look at their stories because they
they're so entertaining is entertaining
you're so funny dude who's Brett man
rock he's a game Hawaii boy oh he's
Hawaiian but he does funny like videos
yeah I love his stories way to you yeah
yeah so he entertains the showed me and
so does Mickey yeah flattered titty
Muhammad I hear she's my friend
I do random stories she loved it it's me
went stickers me with my grasshopper
yeah you get a slice of the sitcom I
don't know you get a slice of the sick
you know I forget that stories exist and
then I get bummed out if I miss out one
of your stories
Oh like dang it she talked about her
grasshopper I didn't see that the other
got check the highlights yeah
grasshopper highlight yeah I do oh my
god and I have a sticker hi and I have a
plant highlight she's fun I love plants
yeah we were talking about that plants
are oh dude Bart's Instagram is everyday
he's fighting in the morning yeah every
day he's showing clothes in the
afternoon and then every day he's with
tyke at night it's like every day it's
like a routine a second part of his life
even know Bert had an Instagram stories
no no he's on he doesn't see a video
post post and I'm like man Bart Scott
like this [ __ ] routine down pat dude
he is a man of routine now very seldom
mine is just watching Leia and I share
with everyone I just watch her and then
I let everyone else watch her and I'm
like I like those you watched her
through the screen if you watched in
real life I want you to the screen cuz I
want to capture and I want to share with
everyone
I like though of the way she faked
Christ she faked guys to get her way I
just like watching kids move their
[ __ ] faces around like though you're
just learning how to you know how to
support their head yeah it's so good I
like their hand I know I got so bummed
when I could learn how to control his
own head that was like I'm gonna miss
that yeah you've got a bobble head
anymore I'm like de - there's a big
subreddit that's called kids falling
it's like our slash kids falling it's
just a bunch of little kids just falling
I need kids and adorable babies and
costumes falling yeah the big lion
costume and falling I just [ __ ] would
die I'd cry laughter you have rubber
bone still so it doesn't even hurt that
exactly you get run over by a whole like
semi truck and they'll be fine and that
didn't happen that way no I mean I'm
obviously exaggerating but they know
Cystic show that it's like a little kid
because their bones are so malleable
like they don't I can survive that's why
we got a harvest bones we got to harvest
those bones and put them in our faces so
are we stay Bravo young yeah we're
always funny when I look at you after
something bad happens cuz if they'll
react on how you yeah oh my god I should
cry now because you're freaking yeah I
actually learned to not do that
immediately through
my son when he was a baby like he
wouldíve me TI i would i just i can't
help it so big oh [ __ ] i can't do that
so then a few Falls I feel like you're
okay you're okay let's go you good what
about it I'm not laughing at them I do
sometimes so she can laugh what she
laughs yeah she'll get up and there's a
lot of times I don't say anything cuz I
just want her to get up and make sure is
like not a big deal and then Christina
goes go come for her get mad at whatever
hurt me like let's say I hit ran into
the table isn't that he'd be like I
start crying be like or - I mean I'm
evil and then he'd be like well and then
I laugh at him reprobated the table but
distract me that's not like you yeah I
just got in trouble for getting hurt
dude nikki has [ __ ] memories from
when she's a baby and [ __ ] - is my
earliest memory but there's only one
memory of them I have one memory as a as
a baby yeah in a beanie I told my
parents this memory and they're like
that's the first day I brought you back
from the hospital memory I was on a
couch crying and there was a table
layout with fish and stuff like that and
I told him this story and it pulled out
the picture and they said that was the
moment you did that and I'm all like
how's that even medically possible but
there's another time when I remember I
had this dream of a flashback I was
crying in bed saddest [ __ ] and then I
was in my first house that I was living
in and and I remember everything the
feeling and then they told me that oh
yeah that actually happened but there's
no picture for it but I described
everything yeah Wow that happened to me
when I saw my baptism video I kind of
like accepted that in my mind yeah like
I remember being there but obviously I
don't
yeah the year old there's this one
memory of my first birthday that I don't
know if it was cuz the picture and then
I
accepted it or if it's an actual memory
anymore because I feel like it's a
memory but then I don't know hmm yeah no
my second birthday though I clearly
remember being in that moment and then I
saw a photo of it later and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I remember that day I can't believe
I was turning to cuz it was my birthday
but I didn't know how old I was
it was triggering a memory that you
actually had of that event right because
then you'd that photo can write off like
write out the rest of the day yeah but I
had thought about that memory before
coming across that photo all right at
least I thought yeah same thing with you
like maybe you didn't see you saw the
photo before yeah I remember seeing
Batman 1989 in the theaters when it came
out and then I remember my dad took me
and my mom and they took me in bought a
Batman cape and I looked at myself in
the mirror the costume store and I was
like holy [ __ ] I look exactly like the
shittiest little [ __ ] cape you look
exactly like [ __ ] Batman there's no
difference to me boy yeah I was like
four years old now oh I wish I could
have that kind of imagination yeah yeah
you don't have this other memory to it
just kind of hooked up but I remember
standing in front of a mirror and like
tripping balls really [ __ ] tripping
out like everything was distorted and
everything like I felt weird and I was
like I had to be younger than five
because at that place we moved out when
I was five and so I don't know I had
this theory that maybe I got into some
drugs I wasn't supposed to get into
they're just eating [ __ ] in the yard
baby had some fertilizer or something
yeah good night my brother was born I
was staying at my aunt babysat me so
that my parents could be at the hospital
so that my mom could give birth to my
brother and they had the big like closet
mirrors you know the mirrors that are
like plenty one and I couldn't sleep cuz
I swore there was a tarantula crawling
up the mirror every time like my aunt
turned out the light and then she turned
on the light and it wouldn't be there
and then like I'm not gonna swear was
there I just saw it and then she turned
off the way and it would start crawling
out again and I'm like what the [ __ ] is
that out I was crying I couldn't I
couldn't sleep and I still vividly
remember like definitely seeing like the
tarantula and then reflection in the
mirror and you're awake when this yeah
that's what I used to have something
like that
every when I was a kid every time I was
gonna get sick I wake up in bed and I'll
go down the stairs and I wouldn't make
it down the stairs I'll be sitting on
top and all these spiders will start
trickling in and covered my entire like
frame of just view and that's what I
knew fevers come in every [ __ ] time
do when I was a little kid it's like
elementary school fever whoa yeah I
don't know
spider spirits I don't know that was the
only time ever that ever happens it was
just a member of the night my brother
was born whoa mm-hmm he was a spy he was
up he was in my shoes he's a cancer
which is like a crab oh she was like a
spider oh I love crab they're so
delicious when I was five I remember I
had a dream where I was getting hit over
and over by football players I was in
Japan so I don't I didn't like even know
what football was I had probably just
seen it but like I was just like why
these like big jersey men like hitting
me I was getting hit back and forth and
I was like maybe in the past life you're
a famous football player that died yeah
bro my accident but I was like dying
like literally and then I wake up and I
wasn't in my bed I was getting carried
by my dad and I was outside and I was
like dad what the [ __ ] is going on he's
like oh you have like the craziest fever
we're taking him tomorrow and it was
later that I was like oh those were
football players that were hitting me on
the field what are the best times when
you wake up and your parents are
carrying you I used to sleep in my
parents bed on purpose and not go to my
room just so they could carry me back so
they could hold you right that's the
best [ __ ] ever I didn't like that [ __ ]
no my dad came in like you're probably a
child [ __ ] you good that's true
[Music]